va réussir stif j'en suis certain parce
que je ne sais pas ce que je ferais sur
un réchaud
[Musique]
bonjour à tous ici votre art go rock
nationale comme vous le savez déjà je
suis le plus grand partisan du voyage
dans le temps concernant avengers 4 je
pense réellement que c'est la seule
solution
et je vous ai apporté énormément
d'éléments qui appuient cette idée le
rôle d'antoine et du vortex temporel
dans le champ quantique le retour de
beaucoup d'acteurs de vilains comme
l'eau qui ou encore crossbones annoncé
dans le film
le fameux plan de steve pour endgame
pourquoi reste-t-il précisément ses
héros et non d'autres le retour de
l'ancien ou encore la photo de peggy
carter bref je crois au voyage dans le
temps et j'en suis même certain
dernièrement suite au tivi spot du super
bowl concernant avengers 4 quelque chose
m'est venue en tête quelque chose que je
n'avais pas pensé auparavant
cette vidéo fait écho à toutes mes
vidéos théorie sur avengers concernant
le voyage dans le temps car c'est une
fois de plus le sujet dont nous allons
traiter
j'aimerais pour commencer revenir sur le
tvscope proposé par marvel ce tivi spot
nous indique très clairement que nous
allons avoir trois visions principal
dans le film
du moins c'est ce que moi je ressens
celui de tony et nebula tort et requête
puis le principal celui de steve rogers
avec black widow war machine et bruce
banner le groupe de steve est composée
de quatre personnes
et c'est notamment lui qui possède
l'idée d'un certain plan bref là où je
veux vous amener c'est de vous rappeler
les traileurs d'avengers infinity world
si nous commençons par le premier
trailer en terminant par le dernier plan
nous voyons très clairement une scène
qui n'a pas été montré du film est bien
injustement
je suis d'avis que les trailers infinity
ward sont également des traileurs
d'avengers 4 je m'explique
retour dans le temps il y a il est
évident que nos avengers vont
certainement essayer d'arrêter thanos
avant qu'ils ne possèdent toutes les
pierres donc qu'ils obtiennent toutes
les pierres avant lui du coup ils vont
certainement passé par plusieurs époques
donc plusieurs films du mc eu
d'où le retour de certains acteurs dans
leurs tenues d euros d'origine de plus
steve possède un plan pour se sortir des
conséquences de thanos blanc qu'il va
partager avec natacha war machine et
banner comme le montre le premier
trailer d'avengers 4 ils ne sont plus
que 4 d'ailleurs dans la planque des
avengers
retournons donc au premier trailer
d'avengers infinity ward dans ce dernier
nous voyons les quatre avengers que je
viens de citer et qui composent le
groupe de steve soit natacha war machine
banner mais cette fois ci en hulk et du
cou captain america
si nous allons plus loin dans l'analyse
effectivement nous retrouvons les héros
disparus lors du snam de thanos qui
serait donc de retour grâce au voyage
dans le temps que le groupe de steve
aurait mené pour rajouter des arguments
steve est mis au premier plan comme le
leader du groupe
un rôle qui est énormément accentuée
dans le premier trailer d'avengers 4 ou
encore le tivi spot il y a donc une
concordance comparé à une infiniti war
où il n'était pas autant mis en avant
ensuite nous voyons que banner a réussi
à devenir hulk et qu'il est prêt pour la
bataille
ce qui est contraire à ce qui nous est
montré dans infinity ward mais
ironiquement supposé pour avengers 4
enfin l'armée du wakanda et présente
derrière eux et ils sont tous présents
non pas sur la plaine de la bataille
mais bien dans la forêt cela voudrait
donc dire que la bataille aurait été
esquivée ou gagner je ne saurais pas
vraiment vous dire
passons maintenant au deuxième trailer
un plan précis nous intéresse celui de
steve face à la noce
dans cette scène du trailer thanos ne
possède que deux pierres sur cinq alors
que dans le vrai film infinity ward il
ne lui manque que celle de vie
normalement alors je vous arrête tout de
suite je sais ce que vous allez me dire
cette scène tout comme le retour de hulk
c'est marketing et pour ne pas spoiler
le film sur le fait que thanos va avoir
toutes les pierres et gagner je suis
effectivement d'accord mais c'est à
double tranchant
cela peut aller beaucoup plus loin que
ça la preuve en est vous ne trouvez pas
ça étrange de la scène de fin du premier
trailer ne soit pas dans le film que
marvel nous aurait trompé pour un film
qui allait forcément marcher comme
infinity ward et surtout que pil poil
steve natacha war machine et hulk sont
présents ce qui me fait également
affirmé ceci est que cette scène est la
dernière scène d'une finity houara avant
que thanos ne gagne si le groupe de
steve voyage dans le temps pour éviter
que thanos ne récupère les pierres ils
devront forcément terminée par celle-ci
déjà pour protéger vision mais notamment
également pour l'ordre chronologique des
événements cette scène est la dernière
dean finity war la boucle serait bouclée
et signifierait la défaite de thanos qui
ne posséderaient pas toutes les pierres
cependant je ne cache pas que des contre
arguments sont possibles et le plus gros
reste celui du physique de steve dans in
game steve ne possède plus de barbe
contrairement à une fi nit ivoire et
notamment le trailer effectivement
antoine sera également de retour parmi
le groupe de 4 et aidera steve mais
quelle sera sa véritable implication
d'après les trailer il n'a pas l'air de
venir dès le début du film mais bien
après en tant qu'élément de résolution
d'ailleurs le voyage dans le temps à
plusieurs manières d'être traités nous
en reparlerons dans une prochaine vidéo
mais est ce que nos héros vont être en
double dans le film comme dans harry
potter et le prisonnier d'azkaban genre
les héros du passé et les héros du futur
retourner dans le passé
ou peut-être que nos héros du futur
reprennent la place des héros du passé
ou le plus probable que nos héros ont
voyagé dans le temps et semer des
graines qui ont permis aux héros du
passé de réussir certaines actions
imaginez si en fait la bataille contre
l'occident avengers 1 serait simplifiée
du aux actes de nos héros retourner dans
le passé ou encore la non existence
d'ultra en arrivant directement à la
conception de vision
nous savons que tous les héros seront de
retour plusieurs acteurs ont confirmé
une énorme scène avec tous les héros
réunis et cela semble logique pour le
finish mais le souci est le suivant est
ce que nos chers avengers vont retourner
dans le passé pour prévenir les actions
de thanos est donc sauvé le passé et y
rester donc abandonner la réalité du
présent et crée deux timeline dont une
totalement catastrophique où vont-ils
essayer de modifier le passé pour
justement avoir des modifications dans
leurs vraies temporalité après tout si
thanos n'a pas pu avoir les pierres dans
le passé cela veut donc dire que les
héros n'auront pas disparu
ces deux possibilités sont en quelque
sorte vrai enfin nous parlons beaucoup
de steve
dernièrement le héros a été mis
énormément en avant et vous savez comme
moi qu'à ventures endgame ne sera pas
rose et ne sera pas une promenade de
santé steve semble être le véritable
leader des derniers avengers
cependant steve est un personnage prêt à
se sacrifier à n'importe quel moment il
est prêt à mourir
sa seule raison d'être aujourd'hui est
de protéger et sauver le monde
je ne vous cache pas que steve est pour
moi le héros le plus probable de nous
quitter
j'émettais la possibilité de retrouver
peggy et qu'il resterait avec elle à son
époque mais il se pourrait qu'elle game
soit en quelque sorte le dernier captain
america la saga de son origine story
d'où le fait qu'il soit énormément mis
en valeur sa mort serait le symbole de
plusieurs choses comme la fin de la
phase 3 de ligne ification total des
avengers de sa réconciliation avec tony
stark et les états unis de la victoire
de la guerre d'un
fini du soldat mort au combat pour
sauver sa patrie plus le temps passe et
plus un décalage énorme secret entre
certains personnages et l'avenir du mc
eu voyez vous réellement black widow ou
encore aux cayes se battre contre un
être supérieur à thann hausse en termes
de puissance pour la phase iv par
exemple mais bref ça ce sera le sujet
d'une prochaine vidéo
en tout cas j'ai vraiment hâte que
avengers quatre sortes
si la vidéo vous a plu n'hésitez pas à
laisser un gros pouce bleus à vous
abonner ou à me suivre sur twitter
écoutez c'était argot rock et que le
liner soit avec vous
[Musique]